in force and I'm sure that um honorable
and right honorable members will ensure
that that rule is stuck to in their
speeches I call the deputy leader of the
opposition Angela Rayner to move the
motion
thank you madam Deputy speaker the
motion before the house is very simple
this is a plea for answers
a plea for charity and a plea for the
truth and the choice that the house
makes today is simple too our demand is
clear end the cover up and begin the
cleanup
we already know that the so-called VIP
Lane for PPE enabled the shameful waste
of taxpayers money and inexcusable
profiteering by unfit and unqualified
providers we know that the government
has already written off at 10 billion
pounds of public funds spent on their
personal protective equipment that was
either unusable
overpriced or undelivered
ministers have admitted that they are
still paying 770
000 pounds a day of taxpayers cash to
store gloves goggles and gowns enough to
pay for 75 000 spaces in after-school
clubs or nineteen thousand in full-time
nursery care
a hundred and six thousand pounds of
that money is sent to China every day
alone to pay for the storage costs
we already know that four billion pounds
worth of unusable PPE has been burnt to
generate power after 70 million PPE
items were sold off for just 400 000
pounds what we don't yet know Madam
Deputy speaker is what was said in
correspondence between the key
participants of the benches opposite and
the unqualified Coronas on the make and
on the take
we don't even know exactly where our
money ended up but we do know that if
ministers get their way this system
could be used again and this Scandal
repeated enriching fraudsters at the
expense of the taxpayer and creating a
new Mountain of waste
foreign
I'm grateful to my honorable friend for
giving for giving away
um she's absolutely right that there's a
scandalous waste of public money here
but equally important is that we know
that our care sector and health sector
was desperate for PPE during the
pandemic specialized canvas in my
constituency actually changed all of
their manufacturing to be able to make
PPE and got a large number of contracts
from Individual trusts but they were
completely unable to get any contracts
uh the Department of Health so alongside
the public money wastage it was also the
fact that we had nurses and carers
unable to access PPE when they
desperately needed at the height of the
pandemic
my honorable friend is absolutely right
there's two points that are made there
which I will come on to in my speech in
Greater detail but one was the lack of
PPE for those on the front line and also
the total disrespect in the way in which
these contracts through the VIP Lane was
handed out at the expense of businesses
up and down the UK who had experience
who could have helped during the
pandemic who were not party to whatsapps
or whatever else that got them to
ministers access to the VIP Lane take
the mystery of a PPE company with links
to a Tory politician while it is for the
authorities to decide whether any law is
broken and I won't be commenting on the
ongoing investigations we do know that
PPE medpro was referred to the VIP Lane
by a sitting member of the cabinet after
lobbying from another Tory politician
five days five days before it was even
legally registered as a company the
house may recall that this particular
company was subsequently awarded two
contracts worth 203 billion pounds to
supply PPE 81 billion million pounds to
supply 210 million Faith Mass was
awarded on May 2020 and 122 million
pound Contractors Supply 25 million
surgical gowns was awarded in June 2020.
Madam Deputy speaker the face Mass
but by this government from medpro for
more than twice the price as identical
items from other suppliers and the
surgical gowns
rejected for use in the NHS uh technical
after a technical inspection all of them
never even used
it points to a total failure of due
diligence and the rotten stench of
cronyism
for giving way um during the early
months of the pandemic I was being
contacted by PPE suppliers known to the
NHS long-term suppliers who told me that
they were being rejected as they were
offering help one of them wrote to me
and he said
pre-april 2020 there was a degree of
total incompetence about the government
handling of pp purchases however by the
way they scrutinized our own offers
thereafter we believe they knew at least
specification wise exactly what they
were doing and that senior managers were
taking steps to use preferred suppliers
even though they were aware these
suppliers had neither the track record
nor the level of competence to produce
compliant Goods what does my right
honorable friend think about that
I think it absolutely stinks and I think
actually my honorable friend is
absolutely right in that the public can
see through this and those businesses
that are pretty angry because they
wanted to do the right thing during the
pandemic they knew it was a situation
that Britain faced that they not faced
before as a global pandemic and they
wanted to do their bit and the
frustration and my right honorable
friend who's right to quote her business
is that there is no question that the
specifications should have been known
and therefore why with all this PPE
bought knowing full well it couldn't be
used
I'm very grateful to my old friend for
giving away does she agree with me that
the the mood in her constituents as in
mine opposite these dealings is one of
Faith being completely shaken in the
good governance and process of this
nation and that people at the very least
are saying that the monies that have
been obtained and goods not properly
utilized has to be returned and if the
circumstances so dictate there should be
Criminal prosecutions long before an
inquiry can progress
yeah I think my honorable friend is
right to capture the mood of the public
on this because at a time where the
public are told that we have to show
restraint at a time where the public can
see the finances not least because of
this government's former prime minister
and Chancellor and the crashing of the
economy but it absolutely Galls them
to think
that ministers opposite were not doing
the due diligence that was required with
the funds that we needed and now we have
this situation where we are spending
billions of pounds on wasted PPE and
we've also got
um thousands of pounds every single day
that has been wasted on storage for PPE
our couple of giveaways but obviously in
government you have to actually get on
and make decisions and we don't often
get to see what the labor party would do
in our place on this occasion on this
occasion on this occasion we did have an
Insight because of course the Lego party
did recommend a whole series of people
that could Supply vital things for the
for this during the pandemic vital
supplies including a football agent
supplying ventilators what assessment
have you made of the equality and
credibility of you as the chair made has
the chair made the labor party's own
suggestions or supplies during the
pandemic
[Music]
I Thank The Honorable member for for his
comments but I actually I'm a ball
member
how many members from across the house
that were not conservative members got
VIP access to the VIP Lanes I can give
the honorable member the answer
non-zilt zero and this is the problem
because the due diligence wasn't done on
those contracts and it was his
government's problem his government's
responsibility and his government's
failure I'll happily giveaway I thank my
honorable friend for giving way and
she's making an excellent speech would
she agree with me that there's a huge
contrast between the comments of the
National Audit office on the way that
the Welsh government procured the PVE
where they were not wasting public money
wherever they're getting value for money
and they were not ending up having to
explain to the house how they gave
contracts to various people would you
not agree with me that that is the way
that labor government in action really
works
yeah I absolutely agree with my
honorable friend and this was a global
pandemic and yet we see it is the UK
government that is constant constantly
criticized about these contracts and the
way in which they were doled out and
given and all this motion to the house
today is asking for is transparency what
have you got to hide say hi I'll happily
give way
I thank the shadow Minister our general
secretary given way I am speaking very
powerful
um speech and the today has been a
really important day because we've met
fire brigades unions and from across the
country who have come down to stand up
for a decent salary that's all we're
asking for and what this illustrates
what this debate illustrates is that the
government can find billions of pounds
to hand over in a crisis to
well-connected supporters and if it's if
the allegations are true of the member
of The Other Place enough money from
that uh as alleged dividend would have
settled the fire fighters settlement in
Scotland in totality one person against
every firefighter and will she confirm
that a labor government an incoming
labor government will investigate this
matter thoroughly and transparently and
hold in anyone who has bent the rules
however they have done so will be helped
in Justice Angela I Thank The Honorable
member for his point and he's absolutely
right and the fbu members the fire
brigade union members were were in
Parliament today and outside and they
they are frustrated like many others who
have been told that there isn't money to
to give them a pay rise and that
actually they're going to get a real
terms pay cut but at the same time
billions of pounds has been wasted and
as I said in my opening uh remarks is
that 770
000 pounds a day on storing this this
equipment it is not it is not acceptable
to most people and most members of the
public I'll happily give one
Madam Deputy speaker I think my original
friend on the front bench giving way
she's highlighted one particular
legal situation but I'm sure she's aware
that the Department of Health and Social
care remains in dispute on 176 contracts
for PPE worth 2.7 billion pounds and I
wondered if she had any thoughts about
that
it
my honorable friend the chair of the
public accountant is absolutely right it
is absolutely eye-watering astonishing
that
176 contracts remain in this situation
and the public can see that the public
can see this and they are frustrated
because it is not acceptable it is not
okay to govern in that way and the
public rightly wants answers and they
want them now now the Links between
then medpro company and the tour
repairing question were never publicly
disclosed in fact they were denied
repeatedly by the lawyers acting for
those involved we now know that the
money ended up in offshore accounts
directly linked to those individuals
by their own admission this was for
so-called tax efficiency it seems they
even dodged paying their own taxes on
the profits they made from ours only
after a long legal battle was it
revealed that there was active lobbying
from ministerial colleagues for access
to the VIP Lane and substantial
contracts were won by those companies
they said that the peering question did
not benefit from these contracts a
denial that has been rather undermined
by the latest Revelations of the
Guardian rather than any disclosure of
ministers because it was only sometime
after the guardian exposed these links
that a minister finally told me in
answer to a parliamentary question that
and I quote
departmental records reflect that a link
between baroness Mon and PPE medpro was
clear prior to contracts being awarded
but ministers have for months refused to
show us those records or tell us the
nature of that link and whether it was
declared or whether it was discovered in
due diligence
this was the subject of an investigation
by the standards Commissioners in the
other place and yet it appears ministers
sat on the information they had
so the question is very simple Madam
Deputy speaker
what have ministers opposite got to hide
did they know all along who was behind
the PPE Med Pro or was due diligence so
poor that they did not realize the
problem
if they had nothing to hide and no rules
or laws were broken their ministers will
surely be happy to make the details of
the meetings and the correspondence
available and while they're at it will
the minister give us clarity about
allegations made by the former Health
secretary in his new book about a
separate bid for business connected to
baronessmo not Mom
um the right honorable lady is venturing
rather too far into the territory that I
urged her to avoid
um I'm afraid that these are the rules
so I do have to bring her up if she is
to pull her up if she is actively
criticizing a member of the other place
I'm sorry about that that is the rule
Angela Rayner
I wasn't criticizing members from the
other place I'm just quoting what a
member from this place who is a health
minister at the time has said and I'm
asking the minister today if he can give
us Clarity on what was said because
that's now public record so that's all
I'm asking the minister for I haven't
said that about any person from the
other place that is what a minister has
said in his diary so it would be nice if
the minister opposite can give us some
light on this whole murky affair
so Madame Deputy speaker let's turn to
the numbers because as they say the
numbers don't lie
10.
how many times the company was more
likely to get a contract if it was in
the VIP Lane
warning five
the proportion of emergency contracts
handed out by the government that have
been flagged for corruption
three and a half billion that's the
value in pounds of contracts given to
the Tory parties mates that we know of 3
billion the value in pounds of contracts
awarded that woman further investigation
non-zilt zero that's the number of times
this government has come clean on this
dodgy Med Pro Scandal a cover-up a
whitewash event swept under the carpet
and now they've been drag Kicking and
Screaming to the house today to give an
honest account about their shameful
dealings the public are sick of being
ripped off and being taken for fools and
they want to know the truth
so today I will give away
is it not clear to the public now that
the party opposite believe in one thing
only and that is how much money they can
grab from the public purse and give to
their crony friends and steal from the
hard-working pockets of people in this
country
friend
the public want answers they want to
know what's happened at the time when
they needed this government the most to
act responsibly what's happened to their
money and what happened with these
contracts so today we've tabled this
motion and we will put it to a vault
let me be clear Madam Deputy speaker
that we're not asking the government to
do anything that would undermine any
chance of recovering our money or that
would conflict with any police
investigation but for 10 months they
have told us that they are in mediation
what progress has been made when will
they conclude it has failed and take
action now
can they actually get our money back or
are they just kicking the can down the
road to our motion ask ministers to hand
over the records the Public Accounts
committee a body this house relies on to
hold them to account for public spending
because the only logical conclusion is
that they do indeed have something to
hide
the public deserve answers on whether
the dodgy Lobby lobbying at the heart of
this Scandal played a part in how vast
sums of taxpays cash has been wasted and
whether shameful profiteering has been
enabled by this government which leads
me to the second simple question for the
house today
will members opposite well the few that
are in will members opposite now vote
for a cleanup or yet another cover-up
just last week the government LED Tory
members in the other place through the
lobbies to block an amendment to their
procurement bill it would have banned
VIP Lanes in future procurement
decisions but they voted it down they
voted to protect unlawful VIP access
instead of protecting taxpayers money
the prime minister is peddling
legislation full of loopholes that would
give Tory ministers free reign to do it
all over again fresh from writing off
billions he carelessly cost to covert
fraud the question for the house is
whether to act to prevent a repeat so
today I say to honorable and write
honorable members opposite learn your
lesson don't let this shameful episode
be repeated
now Madam Deputy speaker
the loss and Trauma of the pandemic was
immense millions of families lost loved
ones some only getting to say goodbye
via iPad as mothers fathers husbands
wives and Friends Slipped Away
and then we learn
that throughout this trauma companies
with WhatsApp links to ministers were
given special VIP access to contracts
which have seen billions poured down the
drain
this government has done Untold damage
to the Public's faith in politics
the first step in restoring this trust
is publishing these documents today
the public need answers about how this
happened and they need them now Madam
Deputy speaker but they also deserve
reassurances that this will never ever
be allowed to happen again
yeah tax pays money
must be treated with respect not handed
out in backroom deals to cronies or a
passport to profiteering and PPE medpro
is just the tip of the iceberg in this
Scandal we now know that companies that
got into the VIP Lane were 10 times more
likely to win a contract we now know
that many did not go through the
so-called eight-stage process of due
diligence as ministers have now admitted
and we now know that this less dozens of
experienced British businesses out in
the cold
businesses who had the expertise to
procure PPE and ventilators precisely
and fast
businesses who offered their help in our
darkest hour and businesses whose only
mistake was to play by the rules
not a single one of the companies
referred to the VIP Lane was done solved
by a politician of any other political
party other than the conservative party
the then Chancellor of the duchy of
Lancaster the cabinet member who oversaw
the entire emergency procurement program
reportedly fast-tracked a bid from one
of his own personal friends and donors
who went on to win hundreds of millions
of pounds of public money last week he
said that he simply referred the bid
from PPE Med Pro onto officials yet we
also know that he passed it directly
onto his ministerial colleague Lord anew
popular giveaway I thank my honorable
friend for giving away and she's given a
very um thoughtful uh speech that should
put everybody on the opposite Ventures
to shame exactly this multiple friend as
shocked as I was to find out that there
was a company that was put on the VIP
Lane by mistake and they still got a
million pound contracts oh gosh wow
it is it is
absolute negligence of due diligence
when the whole process which we now know
um has been tested in the high court
around this VIP Access Lane and what
that did and what it didn't do but we
know that there is serious concerns from
members of the public and that's what
this motion is about today it's about
getting to the bottom of it and I think
the public deserve no less than that but
after the minister passed it directly
onto his ministerial colleague Lord anew
and sometime later officials discussed
that The Minister's office was still
being furiously lobbied the former
Health secretaries also described being
lobbied in words I won't quote in the
chamber Madam Deputy speakers made it
clear but without any dates or details
so we do not know exactly what
conversations our contracts happen
behind the scenes but we do know that
three and a half billion pounds of
contracts that have been handed out by
this government to their political
donors ministers mates and so yes we do
need an investigation into that too in
fact we need an investigation into every
pound and Penny that has been handed out
and to learn the lessons so the public
money isn't wasted again and don't
forget they had previously denied the
existence of a VIP Lane at all well it
existed all right it allowed
conservative politicians to open doors
for anyone with connections to ministers
the WhatsApp Highway Express and earlier
this year the high court declared it
unlawful
that's my right honorable friend
mentioned earlier it didn't have to be
the best way governments across the
world responded to the covid emergency
without wasting billions of pounds of
taxpayers money and relying on dodgy
backroom deals are called into the
Watchdog the Welsh labor government
managed to prevent Health and Care
bodies running out of PPE the Watchdog
said and I quote in contrast to the
position described by the National Audit
office in England we saw no evidence of
a priority being given to potential
suppliers depending on who referred them
the Welsh labor government created an
open transparent PPE supply chain in
stark contrast to the approach the
conservatives took in England
making a powerful speech does she agree
with me that
um with the benefit of hindsight this
house would not have allowed the
government to have the emergency
procurement powers that it granted at
the beginning of the pandemic if we'd
have known
how they were going to be used in this
corruption
I think my honorable friend's absolutely
right and and I'd go further in terms of
the correspondence that I've been
receiving is that the public feel that
and many conservative voters are
absolutely shocked by what they've seen
this conservative government do they
don't believe it speaks to their values
and yet this has happened and yet we
have a procurement Bill going forward
where this could happen again
so for today at least the question
before the house is simple clean up I'll
cover up I know that members across this
house care about our democracy although
we disagree on many things I hope we
agree on the importance of trust in
politics the values of Integrity
professionalism and accountability in
public office The public's wish for more
transparency and accountability within
these four walls put simply a vote for
this motion is a vote in favor of the
truth this government has presided over
scandal after Scandal that has engulfed
their party they appear to have
benefited from dodgy lobbying left right
and center and voting today for yet
another cover-up will send another very
clear message to the public
that this prime minister cares more
about protecting vested interests than
putting things right
that is own promise of Integrity
professionalism and accountability is
just more hot air
after what they've put the British
people through this surely cannot be the
message members opposite want to send
now labor has a plan to put to turn this
procurement racket on its head and
tackle the obscene waste with an office
for value for money to ensure that
public money is spent with the respect
that it deserves it's about time members
opposite got with that program so I say
today and I hope that bench is opposite
are listening let's end the cover-up and
begin the cleanup and start it now and I
commend this motion to the house
yeah
the question is As on the order paper
um I know that's honorable and the right
honorable members heard what I said
previously I just want to add that
whilst these matters are not subdue to
say they are under investigation by law
enforcement agencies and the Lord's
Commissioners for standards and nothing
should be said to Prejudice or pledge to
prejudge or Prejudice any investigations
I'm sure that that will be born in mind
now Minister Wilkins
Madam Deputy speaker and I'm grateful
for the opportunity to come to this
house to talk about our Vital National
efforts on personal protective equipment
colleagues must cast their minds back to
where we were three years ago as we
stood on the precipice of a global
Health Emergency the likes of which had
not been seen for over a century SARS
cov2 was not even called covid-19 by
this point I will in a moment and little
was known about its impact and
transmission
and in a matter of a few short weeks
this novel coronavirus pushed Global
Health Systems and Global PP Supply
chains to near Breaking Point yet here
at home from a standing start we
initiated work on one of the toughest
logistical Challenges ever undertaken in
peacetime the provision of PPE for
Frontline colleagues in Health and
Social care
[Music]
[Applause]
and we at the beginning of the pandemic
in one of my first prime minister's
questions I asked the then prime
minister if he would ensure that
profiteering would have no place in this
government's response to the covet
pandemic and now fast forward all these
years later and that seems to have been
at the very heart and the question that
I have for him is that the British
people were told that this government
was helping them British industry was
told that they were going to be
supported what I have been persisting in
my questions about how the domestic
diagnostic industry has been promised
work by this government and they are
being charged for doing the right thing
will he apologize to them yeah thank you
well um Madame Deputy speaker I'll come
on to many of the points that The
Honorable gentleman raises but I will
just say about this about UK Supply
chains at the beginning of the pandemic
only one percent of PPE used in the UK
was produced here at present three
quarters of the ffp3 mass provided to
the NHS and social care are now
manufactured in the United Kingdom and
contracts were signed with around 30
uk-based companies to manufacture around
3.9 billion items of pp I will in a
moment
now Managed IT so I'll just make some
progress and I will I will come to
colleagues now colleagues will recall
those early days planes turned around on
the tarmac countries imposing export
bans a huge inflation in global prices
and the price of crucial items like
glass increasing six hooks to six folds
now these were the conditions under
which tough decisions were taken these
were the decisions under which PPE was
procured and these were the conditions
Madame Deputy speaker under which we
stepped up to protect our most
vulnerable and save lives
forgiving way but how does he possibly
swear the fact that Arco a leading
clinical PP supplier to the NHS since
its very Inception
is existed in whole for more than 100
years didn't get a sniff
are any contract from the Department of
Health because there weren't anywhere
near a VIP Lane the minister should be
saying sorry at the dispatch box not
always nonsense just fess up say sorry
well Madame deputy there are lots of
words there and lots of aggression and
I'll come on to address some of the well
let's be frank there was let's let's
come on to many of those points because
the honorable gentleman The Honorable
gentleman The Honorable gentleman I I
fear forgets the pressure under which
civil servants were working at the time
and the pace at which decisions had to
be taken and and if if if if the on let
me let me come if the honorable
gentleman would like to write me with
with those exact conditions
or order
will gentlemen must allow the minister
to answer it's not fair just to shout
back as soon as he starts answering
minister
The Honorable gentleman will know that
civil servants had to take decisions
about
speed and pace and quantity they were
looking at contracts that would get the
most amount of pp for the best value of
money as quickly as possible I'll take
mine with a friend's intervention I'm
very very grateful to my honorable
friend for giving way was everything
that was done done perfectly no and all
lessons will be learned I have no doubt
but he does make I think the point which
all of us would be well advised to try
and remember
because it is now quite a long time ago
the absolute panic and fear
the whole world was trying to buy this
stuff at any price that they could get
hold of it
and if we neglect that if we neglect to
remember the doctors and the nurses and
the care home operators and our
constituencies who were knocking on
Outdoors asking for emergency help then
then we can't have a proper debate about
this issue
is absolutely right and under those
circumstances in those conditions we had
to be quick and decisive to protect
colleagues on the front line so that
they could continue providing
life-saving care but with lives on the
line Madam Deputy speaker of course of
course we had to change our approach to
procurement and adjust our appetite for
risk and I don't believe I will in a
moment but I don't believe I don't
believe van and Deputy speaker as my
honorable friend just said that the
British people would have forgiven us if
we'd stuck to the same old processes we
had to balance we had to balance the
risk of contracts not performing and
supplies being sold at a premium against
the real risk Madam Deputy speaker of
harm to the health the Frontline workers
the NHS and the public if we failed
if you want to have it both ways they're
criticizing us for procurement decisions
as I mentioned earlier they recommended
a football agent to supply ventilators
and the same serco company that they
criticize us for having procured PP from
the Welsh labor government also procure
PPE from
well um
to get into a a political slanging match
on on this exact point but but where my
honorable friend is right is that all
members across this house receiving were
receiving multiple emails from people
who were as my honorable friend points
out they were panicking because they
wanted to ensure that we were we were
procuring that PP equipment as quickly
as possible so if an Adaptive speaker
colleagues I will in a moment colleagues
across government and Beyond work day
and night taking tough decisions to keep
our country safe those efforts secured
billions of items now I'm going to come
to civil servants in a moment and and
forgive me forgive me if I won't give
way Madame Deputy speaker
indicated that he will give way in in
shortly so I think let him make a bit
interesting commented lips but I've
actually given way equally to both sides
so far in this debates like there is
some reluctance amount of Deputy speaker
for me to give way to members who tell
other members to sit down whilst they
are speaking or making uh interventions
but Madam Deputy speak I would I wish I
said I would and I will but
those efforts of the civil servants
secured billions of items and by June
2020 we'd obtained 30 000 ventilators
and delivered more than 17.5 billion
billion items of pp to protect from work
now what does this mean in practice
Madam Deputy speaker that we were able
to able to keep our NHS open throughout
the pandemic it meant Emergency
Operations went ahead and what some of
the toughest restrictions were eased it
also meant that relatives could visit
their loved ones in and around Care
Homes I will give way I'm going to set
up for giving way I just want to take
the minister back to where he mentioned
civil servants according to the
government's own records civil servants
were begging ministers not to give
contracts to some of these companies
because they had red flags they were
overcharging the government almost
double the price that they agreed to be
paid which was an extra cost of 50
million pounds to the taxpayers so civil
servants themselves were begging the
government not to act in the corrupt
manner that they did
I'm actually very pleased that The
Honorable lady made that intervention
because that's the first I've ever heard
such an accusation made and if the
honorable lady has evidence of such I
suggest that she presents it and it
might be helpful Madam Deputy speaker if
I just talk uh through the process
thousands of companies made offers
around 430 were processed through the
high priority Lane only 12 percent of
those resulted in a contract due
diligence was carried out on all
companies due diligence carried out by
civil servants Financial accountability
sat with a senior civil servant and
ministers this is important many Deputy
speaker ministers were not involved in
the decision-making process and it was a
team of over 400 civil servants that
processed referrals and undertook due
diligence tests I will come in just one
moment now so on that basis Madam Deputy
speaker will make no apology for
procuring PPE at the pace and volume
that we did and now that the global
market for PPE has stabilized I know
it's easy for some people to point to
the value of goods that are inevitably
now sold at a much lower price than we
paid it is a cheap shot Madam Deputy
speaker and it is one that entirely
misses the point now we adjusted down
the value of our PPE holding as market
prices have changed that is just
standard accounting practice and even
then we're still putting large
quantities of it to use and Madam Deputy
speaker our successes should be judged
under conditions we faced at the height
of the pandemic not with the convenient
benefits of hindsight now let me come to
Civil Service let me come to civil
service and it if I may give the right
normal lady the benefit of my fast
approaching uh four years experience as
a minister we rely Madam deputies
speaker on hard-working civil servants
they are the backbone of our state and
it is my privilege to work with them and
the right-handled lady magnificent she
knows that ministers were not involved
in the decision-making process for PPE
procurement and the due diligence as
I've said was undertaken by a team of
over 400 civil servants now although I'm
I'm a health Minister now I wasn't at
the time and I remember Madame Deputy
speaker as a minister at the department
for working pensions how hard civil
servants worked under the most trying
conditions during the pandemic and those
four I will I promise I will come to
another lady those 400 civil servants
working on PP and a senior accounting
officer took decisions at PACE and under
huge pressure as lives depended on them
did they get everything right no but
they did try their best in a highly
competitive Global Market with
significant challenges in sourcing
procuring and distributing PPE yes they
absolutely did and and I would just very
very gently say to the writer of a lady
that her implied criticism of their
professionalism integrity and
Independence at a time of Crisis now
Madam Deputy speaker with the
convenience and luxury of hindsight is
deeply regrettable of course
I think the minister has been
disingenuous to say that I've never
suggested for one moment that civil
servants do not do an excellent job and
work diligently in their work but why
won't the minister publish the documents
and the emails about what ministers and
what Tory peers and what Tory MPS have
been up to during the pandemic and these
contracts
I'll come to that as I as I said due
diligence was carried out on all
companies procurement decisions were
taken by civil servants Financial
accountability sat with a senior servant
senior at civil seven so of course that
is what the right honorable lady uh is
president look Madam speaker I thank and
applaud our hard-working civil servants
and I would humbly suggest humbly
suggest Madam speaker that someone
aspiring to be our Deputy Prime Minister
should do the same and not seek to throw
them under the metaphorical bus
thank the health Minister for giving way
very early on the public accountant here
with the and the National Audit office
was looking into this issue we know it
was a rush at the beginning but we were
warning early on and the problems
persisted the poor record keeping uh in
fact frankly lack of record keeping in
many cases but we gave the pub this
house gave the government permission to
act fast but not to act fast and loose
and the minister just needs to
acknowledge that yeah what um I I thank
the random lady for for her intervention
I'm going to come on a little bit to
some of the the action that we're going
to take but the right old lady rightly
mentions uh accountability and uh and
it's an important Point details of the
high priority Lane were published on the
17th of November 2021 and updated in
February 2022. now this is an important
Point manager speaker because the right
one will lead you the deputy leader of
the opposition suggests that there is
some kind of cover-up well if there is
Madame Deputy speaker listen to this
because this is this is some kind of
cover-up so high priority Lane details
published on the 17th November and
updated in February of this year the
National Audit office has written three
reports specifically about PPE the
Public Accounts committee has held a
number of evidence sessions the Boardman
review has taken place into a
procurement and we are implementing
their findings in full the independent
public inquiry into the government's
handling of the pandemic is ongoing now
of course there are lessons that we have
to learn and can and should learn Madam
Deputy speaker but there is clear
accountability in this process
Deputy speaker as I mentioned civil
servants I want to put on records my
thanks to the 400 civil servants who
work tirelessly to Source deals from
around the globe buying PPE to the
highest standards and quality and yes
for the best value for the time but it
wasn't only them Madam Deputy speaker it
was a true team effort one that was made
possible through some incredible
collaborations including everyone from
industry to the NHS social care
providers to our Armed Forces they all
played their part and they played it
well now turning Madam Deputy speaker to
unsuitable PP or potential fraud it is a
simple it is a simple truth Madame
Deputy speaker that 97
97 of all PPE we ordered were suitable
and fit for use with only a small
proportion of the billions of items
procured deemed unsuitable now where
that has been the case Madame Deputy
speaker we are actively seeking to
recover costs from suppliers and we're
working to maximize the value from
stockpiles including using PPE in other
settings outside of our NHS equally in
those rare instances where there have
been allegations of fraud my
Department's anti-fraud unit has worked
quickly to investigate and moved to
recover costs now with respect to some
of the specific points raised in today's
motions from the thousands of companies
that made offers around 430 as I have
said were processed through the high
priority Lane and only 12 percent of
them Madam Deputy speaker resulted in a
contract award now the right honorable
lady knows that all contracts went
through the same due diligence process
regardless of the source of the offer
and she also knows manam Deputy speaker
that the Nao has written three reports
about PPE and the Public Accounts
committee has heard a number of hearings
and the writing lady would likely to go
I know into the detail of individual
contracts but she knows madam because
she even alluded to it that my
department is engaged in commercially
sensitive mediation with the relevant
companies with a view to resolving the
issue without recourse to formal legal
action now responding specifically to
the terms of the motion
the government is committed to releasing
information when all investigations are
concluded our response will necessarily
take into account The Wider public
interest and the commercially sensitive
nature of the material it is only right
Madam Deputy speaker that we work with
the Public Accounts committee on the
terms on which information might be
shared and I understand the chancellor
of the duchy of Lancaster will soon
begin a dialogue with the chair of the
PAC on how we enact those information
sharing Arrangements
I think the health Minister for giving
away again and I would just like to
reassure him and the house that the
Public Accounts committee is responsible
and not Reckless the Public Accounts
committee has previously received papers
from this house and we have a very well
established protocol of receiving and
dealing with those papers and the
committee is a trusted committee we
never leak when we decide to publish
that is a choice that we would make but
it is a responsible decision that we
would take
I thank the right honorable lady for
that response and I know the uh the
chancellor of the Dutch of Lancaster
will soon begin that dialogue uh with
I've I have given away once before
The Honorable lady shouldn't be on her
feet when the minister is answering an
intervention from the right honorable
lady at the back because quite simply
she's getting in the way of the dialogue
that's not the polite way to do it right
if her if her intervention is going to
be taken it will be taken in due course
standing up for a long time when there's
another dialogue going on is really not
very polite Minister thank you um thank
you madam speaker I have given away a
given way to The Honorable lady once
already and I have been generous with my
time and I I'm not going to give way uh
one more time I have given give away
once before as I promised I would I also
gave gateway to the honorable gentleman
too so let's now we should be proud of
the remarkable progress that we have
made on PPE we are now in a position
where we are confident we have enough
stock to cover all future demands
arising from covid-19 the right
honorable lady mentions some figures in
relation to storage costs I'm pleased to
say they are now significantly reduced
in our right to honorable lady uh with
those uh the the costs of storing that
PPE here in the UK moreover we've
strengthened our country's PPE supply
chain for the long term including
manufacturing more PPE here in the UK
before the pandemic as I said Madam
Deputy speaker at the beginning of this
speech just one percent of our PP was
reduced produced here now the government
has awarded contracts worth with around
30 manufacturers for the supply of
almost 4 billion items of PPE now we we
have we have learned many lessons uh
Madam Deputy speaker from this pandemic
and when it comes to PPE we are in a
stronger footing today than ever before
but the successes of our enormous
National effort at a time of
unprecedented National crisis deserve to
be recognized people from all walks of
life came together to protect people in
the NHS and social care and in doing so
they saved lives even as we continue to
learn and build a system fit for the
future this government will remain
enormously proud of everything that was
achieved
Brendan O'Hara
my name is
robust performance and he said at the
end that the government has learned many
lessons and lesson number one appears to
be apologize for nothing and the
minister knows that no one that I helped
was criticizing the civil servants
everyone on this side of the house knows
that the civil servants were working in
impossible conditions and conditions
that were created by this government and
and I understand and I can see that he's
been told to come out swinging and
apologize for nothing because let's be
honest from the moment we first learned
about the existence of this VIP Lane for
the politically connected it was almost
inevitable that it was come to this the
members of this house discussing the
vast eye-watering sons of public money
that was earmarked for procuring Vital
protective equipment during the pandemic
but which instead has found its way into
the hands of Fly by Night Chances with
little and no knowledge or experience of
PPE procurement but who this was
probably the most charitable thing I
could say about them who became
fabulously wealthy while making an
absolute pigsier of it while trying to
learn on the job and long before
how did the brains behind this get rich
quick scheme ever believe that a plan in
which the government would fast track
its cronies their politically connected
Pals and now it would appear the
Parliamentary colleagues was ever going
to end well
and I do suspect Madame Deputy speaker
as I said during the Urgent question on
November the 24th that the absolute
shocking allegations that have been
leveled against PPE Med Pro both in the
guardian and in the times
and allegations which lead directly to a
member of the other house may well be
the tip of a very very large Iceberg and
I suspect that the reason that the
government has been so reluctant to
release the papers containing the advice
and the correspondence and all the
communication between ministers special
advisors relating to the awarding of
that contract is because it didn't want
to create a precedent one which would
require them to open the Pandora's box
that is a VIP Lane for PPE procurement
but the minister would do well to
remember there is another precedent here
it was a similarities between today's
motion and the motion of the 17th of
November last year when they were
instructed to release a papers in
relation to the randox Owen Patterson
Scandal are absolutely striking and
they'll recall to how that Scandal
rumbled on into February into two and a
half months fight before the papers were
finally made available
was also similar to last year's debate
it goes to the heart of today's debate
as well it's the same very simple
question
has this government got something to
hide is there something this government
does not want us to see because the
minister must be aware
that the more they dodged scrutiny so
the public suspicion will grow that this
PPE procurement program was little more
than the get rich quick scheme for the
politically connected Pals and given
what we already know
you can blame the public for thinking
that because by line times recently said
that the covert contract winners but
direct result to the consent direct
links to the conservative party that's
donors and Associates I've seen their
Collective financial position improve by
in excess of 300 million pounds and was
anyone really that surprised when
private eye described and I quote how
the department for Health and Social
cares London controlled PPE cell was
dishing out contracts like confetti to
opportunistic businessmen I shall what
do you think the Scottish public would
think about the Scottish government
awarding PPE contracts I think over 20
suppliers without competition who are
brand new weren't known suppliers that
have come before that but I think about
that this is a I hate to see it but my
goodness you're predictable sir it was
probably the most predictable question I
could ever have imagined and I will come
on to it later in my speech I will come
on later time I speak because the audit
of the Scottish government's uh the
treatment of the procurement process
compared to what went on in this place
is squeaky clean and I look so forward
to having this conversation in about six
minutes
because what happened is that many of
these opportunists hit the jackpot on
the government's VIP Lane for PPE
procurement and prominent among them but
PPE made pro whose bid to supply the UK
government with face masks and surgical
gowns but put on this high priority Lane
after what we were told was some
particularly enthusiastic lobbying
carried out on their behalf by someone
down the corridor they're indeed so
enthusiastic was the appearing question
about the abilities of PPE Med Pro to
deliver that she made her passionate
pitch to The ministers even before the
company was incorporated and had a
remarkable powers of persuasion
persuaded ministers to propel this
embryonic company one with no experience
in delivering medical or protective
equipment and one of which she told him
she had no personal involvement and had
stood to gain no way financially from
straight into the VIP Lane and on 20
another 20 order I will just remind The
Honorable gentleman he's in danger of
straying I've let him go so far but I
just remind The Honorable gentleman as I
remind the house of what the deputy
speaker said at the beginning of this
debate that the normal rule
that Reflections must not be cast upon
members of either house of parliament
except on a substantive motion which
this is not remains enforced so I know
the honorable gentleman will be careful
in what he said
and I I will attempt to to stay on the
right side of that line and I'm sure you
will instruct me should I Stray again
but when this company was propelled into
the VIP Lane
on the 25th of June 2020 just 44 days
after the firm had been legally
Incorporated PPE may drop a med Pro was
handed its first UK government contract
with almost 81 million pounds to supply
face masks
very shortly thereafter they rewarded a
second contract with an excess of 120
million pounds to supply 25 million
surgical gowns earlier this year the
garden reported that they'd seen the
contract that was signed between PPE
Metro and the ground manufacturer in
China
the place that they've paid for those
gowns was 46 million pounds and even
adding on a bit for shipping and
Logistics and Storage by any reasonable
calculation that leaves a whopping
profit of somewhere around 70 million
pounds of public money on a contract
with 120 million
and to add then salt to injury when the
cargo of gowns finally arrived a quick
technical inspection from the National
Health Service they made them not fit
for purpose and they were never used I
mean I understand
that this situation is so serious that
the company is currently under
investigation by the National Crime
agency
but inexplicably up until a couple of
years ago the peer involved was still
operating under the conservative party
Whip and as I honorable member for
National underline said this stinks we
know it states and the putter order
order I'm quite sure that the honorable
gentleman intends to toast about the
process and the goods Etc and that he
will not be mentioning any peer in
particular and he said the peer involved
so it wasn't just peers in general but a
particular peer and I'm sure that he
doesn't want to make reference to any
particular peer but we'll just talk
about the process
I shove from now on my own objective
speaker thank you
because the
Pro this whole process
what this government knew
this government who deliberately created
the conditions in which behavior like
this could flourish
and they have to release what they know
I will give away
I'm grateful to my little friend
together could I
taken back to his comments earlier about
due diligence now we'll have to minister
a few minutes ago claiming that due
diligence was carried out in every
single case is it possible for even the
top civil servants in the United Kingdom
to do any sort of due diligence and a
company that didn't exist two or three
weeks before
I think it's an excellent question and
and perhaps it's a question that had he
managed to intervene in the minister the
minister would have been far better
place than I to answer but I I do find
it absolutely remarkable how due
diligence can be carried out on a
company which didn't actually exist
so the government knows that there are
less of the PPE medal papers made
through papers
it's not going to make this magically
disappear and they're quite right to
fear that in releasing those files they
are likely to blow the lid off this
Pandora's Box and one of which will
reveal that it's VIP Lane for
politically connected Pals was simply a
green light for unfettered chronic
capitalism rampant profiteering and
widespread abuse of public funds
in his answer
to the object question in November 24th
the minister the under Secretary of
Health for Health and Social care told
this house and I quote
there was a global Scramble for PPE it
was an extraordinary situation in which
we had to act in a different way and and
it's a defense at the minister himself a
moment ago also tried to hide behind and
it may be true
that things had to be done slightly
differently but what is undeniable is
that the UK government made an active
choice to act in the way that it did it
was a political choice to make this an
all-in free market Jamboree and
thankfully and you know and they did not
need to do so it was a political choice
to make this an all-in free market
Jamboree and thankfully and in response
to the honorable gentleman's chuntering
the Scottish government acted in an
entirely different way and of course
many items a PPE for Scotland had to be
served had to be sold from oversea but
the big difference and if he would stop
talking and listening I will explain his
answer no chance but the big difference
was that our government said staff from
Scottish Enterprise over to China to
Source the items we need and should they
were made to an acceptable standard and
were delivered at a cost that we could
afford and at the same time the Scottish
government was increasingly working with
Scottish manufacturers so that by April
2021 88 of our PPE was being produced in
Scotland
about two seconds and that government
involvement had a huge impact on the
price unit cost showed that disposable
face masks close to NHS in Scotland 31
Pence each while the Department of
Health and Social care in England paid
40 Pence that's an increase of 29
percent
I'm grateful to want to move in for
giving me and I can personally vouch for
what he said about the development of
the manufacturing industry in Scotland
because there's an outstanding
manufacturer in my Constitution so they
did exactly that they come in and worked
on paid over the weekend to reset their
production lines to make what was needed
instead of the high quality stuff
they've been producing before does my
normal friend think it is sad that I
can't name that company and sing the
praises today because I don't know if
they would thank me for connecting them
even tangentially to some of what the
subject of this debate is about isn't it
sad that even the outstanding good
Scottish firms are in danger of being
tired with the same brush this has been
applied yeah I think I think meets an
absolutely excellent point and that all
of the good
that we could and should be talking
about
is being lost by this tarnished
reputation and and he could just as
easily have pointed to the Scotch
whiskey Association which pivoted very
very quickly for using his alcohol and
turning it in to hand gel and millions
and millions of gallons of hand gel but
the Scottish government's involvement
was absolutely crucial in controlling
the price and I said disposable face
masks 29 cheaper because they were
supposed support they were bought by the
Scottish government directly of it if
ffp3 face mask Scottish government two
pounds eight Pence a unit Health and
Social care two pound fifty one
a fifth higher disposable gloves
Scottish NHS nine Pence in England
33 higher at 12 Pence even the cost for
non-sterile gloves the Scottish
government is 10 cheaper now one would
have thought that a country with a
population 1 12 of the population of
England would have a real job in pushing
unit costs down below the level of a
country 12 times its size
but it goes back to the fact that the
approach that the Scottish government
took meant that it was in control of
every part of the process and it secured
the deals that didn't require a price
absolutely
the member is talking about the Scottish
government's trap record on procurement
how you bring value to money to the to
the piece do you think that's applied
across the piece how well do you think
you're doing on when it comes to very
procurement in Scotland
that's remarkable you can you can always
spot when authorities thinking beneath
the waves when you start shooting
fairies at you so and and of course
let's remember this this is this is the
government who evolved in a ferry
contract to a company
actually that contract the seabon
ferries contract cost 30 million pounds
isn't it not the case that people in
Glass Houses ought not to throw stones
what one would have hoped that people in
Glass Houses having thrown the first
stone would have realized that perhaps
it wasn't the best idea but while we're
talking about procurement and let me put
on record Madame decorative speaker that
the NHS in Scotland used emergency
procurement Provisions to avoid PPE
contracts without competition during the
first wave of covert 19. but and
crucially the Auditors are completely
satisfied that the procurement
Arrangements were in place as saying
that there was and I quote no evidence
of preferential treatment or bias in the
awarding of contracts in Scotland
I believe that that is the significant
reason
why overall a cost of the pandemic
procurement for less than a third year
of the UK and it perhaps explains again
why the government allowed paying 770
000 pounds every single day to store PPE
in China and the the Menace will be
aware I have tabled a series of
questions today to ask how much of that
is still usable how much of it meets the
standards required for the UK and to ask
probing questions about hello the
quality control methods were used in
securing that can you explain that and
that the proportion of PPE that did not
meet the standard required for the view
I will give way if the minister could
tell us you know exactly the the
proportion of PPE that was produced that
did not meet the standard in the UK
quickly update the houses of October we
hold 13.1 billion items of PPE we have
disposed of 145 000 pallets of excess
stocks so far the majority is stored in
UK sites around 120 million items are
still stored in China the total cost of
storage is now below 400 000 pounds a
day so significantly less than an
objective and says and the total cost
for storage in China is 35 000 a day so
uh
I I think I I generally thank the
minister for that information and I do
look forward to re-reading it hands-off
until I can actually digest it but I did
think if I'm connected we're now on half
a million pounds a day and storing PPE
so so so and and in conclusion Madam
Deputy speaker
having to do things differently doesn't
give anyone whether they're a private
individual an elected politician or an
unelected politician a license to rip up
the rule book and behave as if we live
live in an unregulated wild west of
public procurement and that is why it is
vital
that these papers are released because
the public has a right to know why while
doctors and nurses and other medical
staffs battled and vaccinated through
the worst of this pandemic and as a
public student cheer them in grateful
thanks why some people with connections
to this government saw only the
opportunity to make themselves a quick
book and finally I do predict that this
PPE Metro Scandal is the tip of a very
large ice bear and iceberg that will
eventually sync this Ship of Fools yeah
yeah
Nick Smith
thank you madam Deputy speaker they
write to support the motion of PPE
this has become a terrible tale of waste
for our country
firstly having purchased so much PPE the
taxpay is now paying to store and as
I've discovered Bern a great deal of it
second the abandoned profiteers some
having taken advantage of their
political links exploited our country's
desperation
many of these opportunists used in
chicanery and secrecy made eye-watering
profits and now the UK Department of
Health is withholding information on the
cost of Staffing its contractual battles
with some of these PPE suppliers
Madam Deputy speaker I want to address
the continuing cost of PPE storage
a government response to questions I
asked Jess lastman said the department
currently holds 13.2 billion items of
PPE the cost of storing this is a
staggering 770
000 pounds a day now we've gestured an
update to that I was going to go into
some other data but that's still uh
gonna be a thing about 128 million
pounds a year Madam Deputy speaker if
you run that app over the year ahead
that's half the cost of a brand spanking
new hospital and it's a disgrace
uh secondly Marvin Deputy speaker we've
come to hear about the modern day
Pirates whose business accounts have
been almost impossible to trace and
track thanks to the Sunday Times we've
heard of a network of companies with
connections to conservative lobbyists
one being Sante Global formerly unispace
health
private eye deserve a medal for their
digging deeper here their profits of
Doom special highlighted how unispace
Global limited when PPE contracts worth
nearly 700 million pounds Richard Brook
is fantastic during this day
reports suggest that they have accounted
for their profits through different
companies to those known to the
Department of Health
so it's impossible to see how much money
they've made Madame Deputy speaker this
is shrouded in secrecy due to our feeble
accountancy laws
Madam Deputy speaker the taxpayer
deserves to know who is profiting from
contracts awarded to the government with
public money for the public benefit
it is a high time that this game of PPE
treasure hunt came to an end we need
full open accounting for covid-19
contracts
these companies should be made to
publish full details of their income
their profits their commissions their
dividends and their big bosses bonuses
then the chancellor I think should
consider a windfall tax on these super
profits
Madam Deputy speaker the government
could also learn a lesson in
transparency
in my experience in recent months it's
trying to dodge questions on the
continuing cost of PBE last month I
asked the Secretary of State for health
how much unused PPE had been donated
sold recycled and incinerated since the
start of the pandemic
no answer yet I also are asked when he
plans to publish the forecast of the
cost of resolving these ongoing
contractual disputes we've heard a lot
about today again no answer yet
no there are disputed contracts with 2.6
billion pounds with 176 companies
babamount could buy a seven new
hospitals
it's important the government pursues
this money so all power to the elbows
however I think transparency on its
processes could really help this cause
because the more we all understand the
better we can hold the Bad actors to
account
Madam Deputy speaker we should support
the motion today
as long as the long tail of covered
costs continues
covid contracts need to be cleared up
and the Department of Health must come
clean thank you madam Deputy speaker
Don Butler
Deputy speaker
um just a few points for the minister is
no longer in his place the National
Audit office did not have all the
paperwork it needed to give a full and
correct report so therefore the minister
keeps quoting the national auditory
saying that due diligence was done on
all companies is not correct and also
the NHS published weekly consumption
data during the pandemic so really the
question is how on Earth did we come to
buy five times more PPE than we actually
needed exactly it makes no sense and and
there's a lot of evidence and paperwork
on the good Lords project website Just
For The Minister's reference but Madam
Deputy speaker coronavirus pandemic has
been a nightmare for everyone it was you
know a time of national pain and loss
and for some it was unspeakable you know
they lost loved ones I lost a loved ones
and it was also financially damaging for
the country but it is absolutely
shocking
and unforgivable that some people took
the opportunity to see this crisis as an
opportunity to seriously line their own
Pockets making money out of the misery
we all went through let's be clear this
money
is not free money this money comes from
working people through taxation and the
government's been pocketing the working
class to fund the lifestyle of the Rich
and we still don't know the true extent
of the misuse of public money and that's
why this motion is important today
because even though I and many others
have been asking questions for three
years what comes back from the
government is really quite sparse and
we're having to piece together the
information and that's not good enough
for a government need to be transparent
and honest and the public deserve to
know who was given public funds and how
many had links to the conservatives and
what they were paid for because I often
asked what were they paid for what kind
of PPE how many and how many did we
receive and the minister never comes
back with that information so if The
Minister's got the facts and figures for
each company broken down I'd appreciate
that the minister puts that in the diary
and apparently according to the minister
last week some companies were paid for
EP even though we had enough PPE in
stock so and I said was that deliberate
and he said yes and I think that's
really quite strange have we've got
enough PPE you're giving people more PPE
of course
oh God and The Honorable member claims
that we bought five times too much PPE
this is not the case we did have 20
excess capacity against a worst case
scenario which thankfully didn't
materialize but just to be clear to the
normal lady it is not the case as she
keeps saying that we bought five times
too much BP it is simply not the case
thank the minister for that intervention
so can the minister just clarify if the
NHS was given weekly stats and how much
PP was needed how comes there's so many
much PP in storage that's costing 750
000 pounds a day a day to store but the
minister want to come back oh Minister's
walked in at the right time
it's on that point it's not the seven
hundred thousand figure descriptive but
just on this point it is not the case
that we bought five times too much BP
you should keep saying this it's not the
case
and Deputy speaker I suppose the facts
will the facts will reveal itself when
the minister uh shows all of the
paperwork and leaves it in the library
and then we can go through the facts and
the stats and the figures together I
look forward to that
um the the thing is that and we've heard
earlier today
that the we heard earlier today that
going through some figures now um Madame
Deputy speaker I really think that to
resolve all of this to not even have
this debate and conversation which is
all the paperwork in the library we can
all go through it together and that is
and and that is what's needed of course
I've been waited making a really
powerful speech as she has done and
spoken with incredible experience and
heart throughout
um the last few years on this this
subject but does she agree with me that
particularly galling that we are seeing
the former Health secretary write a book
on the pandemic Diaries and yet we are
not getting able we are not able to
scrutinize the facts and the evidence of
the decisions that were taken not just
about the Public's money but also about
the public safety as well
my only friend makes a extremely valid
point and the thing is is that I've
spoken committee this morning and I'm
not going to read the book but I think
we really do have to scrutinize that
book and cross-check the information
that the minister gave in committee to
what he's put in his book and I do I do
think that the new ministers that have
come into post really should be a little
bit more humble because what has
happened is really shocking the cronyism
and the corruption that has happened in
the government in plain sight is truly
truly shocking and now the government is
now the government is spending 10
million pounds burning PPE I mean it's
like you're burning the evidence you
wonder why Madame Deputy speaker like
covert covid covid hasn't also sorry the
minister said I've just criticized the
minister for storing it yes you're right
I wouldn't want the minister to spend
nearly a million pounds of everyday
store in PPE I I also don't want the
minister to burn PPE the minister should
be using the pp give it to people who
are traveling on the tube we're having a
flu epidemic you know it will help
resolve that so don't don't Heckle me
when this is your responsibility
I mean this government is totally like
in its sorry madam anyway the government
is incompetent as well as collaborative
speaker and and it's not just cronyism I
mean this situation this situation is so
ridiculous
I am I not allowed to call it what it is
it smells like corruption to me or
perfectly perfectly in order for The
Honorable lady to say incompetent but I
would be grateful if she would find
another form of words rather than saying
corrupt
delicious
but I mean Madam speaker this is this is
so ridiculous that when the Netflix
series comes out nobody's going to
believe this is a true story I mean
recently it was revealed and I know
we're not supposed to speak about the
conservative peer too much but we do
learn today that they're taking a leave
of absence from the Lord and I mean I do
hope and I'm not saying this ingest
Madam did you speaker but I do hope that
she's not on her yacht trying to do a
run
um because there's there's a lot there's
a lot of money that's gone that's um
gone missing and by and by the the
previous Minister's own words
um he was being bullied into giving this
contract I know I don't deserve it but
he was being bullied uh and and two
ministers were being bullied so Madam
Deputy speaker it is important that we
investigate this VIP Lane the National
Audit said companies as a I said earlier
companies were put there by mistake and
they were still given millions of pounds
that surely shows you that due diligence
wasn't done because the company was
there by mistake how did they get all
that money and when the minister gets to
um his feet I wonder if he could tell
the house how many of these companies
existed before the pandemic if the
minister can't then of course we look
forward to that information in the
library or when this motion passes today
which I hope it does and for the
avoidance of any doubt we all know that
the the pp uh the VIP Lane uh was a bit
dodgy
um and that is just a fact and it's on
record but this is this has all come to
light not because Parliament has managed
to force the government to to reveal
everything that's happened it's come to
light because a bank reported unusual
activity wow and have dropped a certain
person and her husband in fear of
reputational damage that is what's for
this particular Scandal to light and the
National Crime agency is now
investigated and
um and the thing is this the serious
Fraud Office is also investigating
contracts and as other people have said
this is just a tip of a very very large
Iceberg and the serious Fraud Office is
also investigating contracts one by
another company
Pharmaceuticals direct limited which
paid a whopping 20 million pound fee to
a middleman wow subject Sergio who
worked for Samir just sell and together
they had a hotline to Boris Johnson
special advisor manira Mirza and we also
know because we've seen the emails that
they were helped by Matt Hancock and
pretty Patel 20 million pounds for a
middleman so the question is why does a
company if it's going to go through due
diligence and believes that it's uh
participating in a proper process why
would they agreed to pay somebody 20
million pounds wow to a politically
connected middleman how that doesn't
make any sense does it because if
everybody treated the same you don't
need to pay somebody 20 million pounds
to move you up the list it's you know as
I said we can't say the word corruption
I'm trying to think of other words
hopefully uh more will come to me and I
will use those but I feel that it feels
very much like a cash for covid contract
and it's a mystery what's happened to
that money 18 months after the case was
referred the series Ford office is still
continue to investigate it there are so
many more uh Madam Deputy speaker that I
can speak about there is a thread
my Twitter if anybody's interested it
talks about some of the other companies
where there are huge questions to be
answered but the government needs to
open up its books the government needs
to ensure that there is proper scrutiny
um because yes of course we accept
mistakes uh were made and some of them
were unavoidable but the the
um Health Department didn't do the fraud
checks that it was supposed to do and we
had to push him it didn't come out to a
whole year later there's been negligence
but there's been something a little bit
more Sinister happening in government
and there's people who have stolen money
from the public person during a national
crisis this those people should be
ashamed it's not patriotic don't say I
was doing it for the country you're not
doing it for the country when you're
pocketing millions of pounds it's it's
not patriotic Madam Deputy speaker it is
a word that you're not happy with me
using
um they will they will have had the
people who have taken this money
unlawfully really but really it was
helped by government ministers but the
people who have taken this money have
had plenty of interest payments from
their ill-gotten gains but now is the
time during the cost of living crisis to
give that money back and that includes
Madam Deputy speaker the donations that
have been given from these people that
have had a bung from this covid crisis
the donations to the Tory party need to
come back into the public Perth
I'll have to put a time limit on now of
four minutes
um
as an opposition we expect to scrutinize
government to hold them to account and
challenge them and policing legislative
legislature but never did I imagine
scandals favors and Dodger deals through
VIP lens the contract we're focusing on
today is about the 200 million deal to
provide PPE to the government at the
height of birth covid-19 lockdown
allegedly awarded to a company LinkedIn
lobbied by Tory Pier who also happened
to benefit around the tune of 29 million
pounds transferred to an offshore
account which is linked to her and her
children the seriousness of this case is
such that earlier this year the police
raided two London properties linked to
Victoria Pier as well as four properties
on the Isle of Man in support of an
ongoing fraud investigation by the
National Crime agency we're literally
speaking about a criminal fraud
investigation where the trail leads
directly back to the center of
government consistently the government
line has been that they were doing their
best to ensure the best quality of PPE
could be secured and used during the
corvid 9 19 pandemic the truth is the
government was ripping up the ripping
off the British taxpayer to help the
pockets of their friends in May 2020
Baron s mourn referred PPE Med Pro to
the cabinet office for potential
multi-million pounds PPE contract five
days before it was even registered as a
company what track record can a company
that doesn't even exist have to deliver
millions of pounds of PPE of the
government disagree in significant
contrast is multi-brands like many other
businesses across the country multiband
International Limited a bradford-based
business in my constituency Incorporated
in 1998 which provided PPE and had an
operation in China since 2006 a support
office in India since 2010 a legitimate
and established company was denied the
opportunity to provide government PPE at
the time multiple International wrote to
me and asked the question what does our
government do for businesses like us is
it because we are Northern is it because
we choose to operate legitimately or is
it because we don't have secret dealings
with MPS we were never given a chance
and shamefully that there is the truth
they were never given a chance because
unlike the then Health secretary's local
mate from the pope they didn't have his
WhatsApp number or any of the Tory
ministers private numbers or direct
access email to a Tory Minister instead
ripoff contracts were given to their
Tory friends to profit from the British
taxpayer in my neck of the woods the
idea of merch rates is when you
generally get a bad deal and usually it
goes something like this well I'd
normally charge a fiver but because if
you would even me I'll knock you off a
few pennies exactly in this case
according to documents leaked over time
it shows that during the pandemic PPA
PPE Med Pro supplied masks at a cost of
38 and a half Pence each to the
government the same math not later down
valued at the same time same company
were provided to other suppliers for as
little as 14 and a half Pence no one
rips off their ends but it was okay for
the Tories and their cronies to report
for British taxpayer
8.7 billion was written up including 4
billion that was spent on PP which did
not meet NHS standards
National Audit office revealed the Doh
paid 456 million in penalties because
they have to store PPE
that's more than a Year's budget for my
whole local Council in Bradford at 2021
2022 and that could have with 8.7
billion that's written off we could have
had those three hospitals whilsted the
health ministers here in Bradford
including the first carbon neutral one
including a state of the art one in
Bradford City Center replacing two in my
constituency the British people will not
forgive them for ripping off whilst
they're suffer for winter where they
choose between eating and eating so
publisher documents come clean and
ultimately as in the words of the lead
actually River labor party when she
opened up this debate
stop the cover up and start to clean up
yeah yeah you're with them
yeah Madam's actually speaker there's
government's actions on PPE were a
catalog of failures from start to finish
and with devastating consequences before
coronavirus the existing PP stockpile
didn't include everything it should have
then the government was slow off the
mark it took too long to understand that
we would need more PPE and fail to get
on with ordering it this meant that in
the first wave of the Pandemic those on
the front line were left dangerously
exposed
I know because when I return to care at
work to help relieve the strain on my
former colleagues I saw firsthand masks
being rationed and visors donated by the
public when I spoke out about these PPE
shortages members on the opposite
benches insinuated that I was lying
among them and I've informed the members
that I'll be referencing them with a
foreign secretary the right honorable
member for Mid bedfordshire a health
minister at the time and the honorable
member for Mansfield now despite reports
after reports proving that there were PP
shortages and I was telling the truth
not one has ever apologized for these
comments it's not me I want them to
apologize to but the millions in the
care sector both staff and people they
were caring for who were forgotten and
neglected by their governments
foreign
workers lives at risk as well as people
receiving care while those workers
overwhelmingly women and
disproportionately migrants poverty
wages but of course that wasn't
everybody's experience of the pandemic
well my former colleagues work day and
night for a pittance and with some
carers paying with their lives the rich
saw the chance to cash in
one businessman's company made a 70
million pound profit on a contract for
PPE that was reportedly not suitable for
the NHS and therefore went unused he
paid himself 13 million pounds and
celebrated his birthday last week by
eating a cake-shaped like a briefcase of
cash on a private yacht
mela's designs was awarded PPE contracts
worth more than 170 million in 2020 it
made profits of over 13 million that's a
9 000 increase on the previous year and
one of the co-owners had donated nearly
60 000 pounds to conservative
politicians and the central party since
2009.
unsurprisingly the company was referred
to the fast track VIP Lane by a
conservative minister
once the government started ordering PPE
Madam Deputy speaker all too often it
wasn't about who could Supply the best
the fastest at a reasonable price it was
about who had connections to the party
opposite
those refer to the VIP line lane were 10
times more likely to be awarded
contracts
so the government acted unlawfully
wasted billions of pounds in taxpayers
money in the process and failed to
protect those on the front line
Muslim Deputy speaker we talk about how
corruption Rob citizens and ruins public
services in countries across the world
but when it's happening right here in
front of our very eyes we dress it up in
euphemisms
so I urge the government to come clean
and release all the papers relating to
the awarding of contracts yes to Med Pro
but also to all contracts awarded
through the VIP Lane
Christine Jordan
Deputy speaker I rise today to support
this motion but the sentiment I feel
most strongly is what a mess what an
unnecessary unmitigated mess
we've heard a lot from the benches
opposite about how difficult it was at
the time we all know how difficult it
was at the time we all experienced it
we've heard a lot about having to be
quick and decisive the pressure that
people were working under the lives were
at stake I wonder the minister
appreciates
that's exactly why people are so angry
at this
because we all went through it and we
all experienced it and the thing that we
remarked upon most I think at that time
was the spirit in the country and how
everybody got behind the government even
those of us and you know whose job is to
scrutinized the government we got behind
the government people had faith in the
government believed in the government
supported them and now three years down
the line we're waking up every morning
to yet another news story can do another
Scandal more suggestions about what
might have gone wrong and people feel
let down they feel betrayed the numbers
the numbers are frightening two billion
pounds at one point of tax but taxpayers
money wasted on contracts for PPE now
it's almost 10 billion we're told was
wasted on PPE in total we're hearing
about PPE being stored being burned
that's not really the issue for the
people in my constituency and elsewhere
in the country who are struggling this
winter to make ends meet to have got
massive energy bills who wonder if
they're going to be able to feed their
children who are worried about what
their mortgages are going to cost
what is bothering them
is that when they were putting their
faith in the government
when they believed in the government
that we were all in this together
that maybe we weren't hmm the suggestion
now that some people were profiting
from other people's pain
and that is why
in supporting this motion
I would put a plea to the government to
listen to what we're seeing what we're
seeing is not you know civil servants
were wrong that the government was you
know what we're seeing is
people need to know what actually went
on they need some transparency when the
Prime Minister the latest prime minister
became prime minister he promised us
a government that would be ethical
would have its heart doing the right
thing well we need him to be good as
that would know
we need him to make it clear that he
will leave no stone unturned that his
government will leave no possibility of
anything sleazy of any cronyism of
anyone having profited
at the cost and the expense of the
British public at a time of extreme
because it was extreme National crisis
that is why this debate debate today is
important that is what we need from the
government now we need something of that
spirit that we had back then when things
looked so dark we were all worried
for ourselves for our families for our
health for our futures
we need something of that Spirit now and
for the government
to stick by what the Prime Minister has
said
and to give us the transparency let us
see the peoples put everything out in
the open
please
ban VIP lanes because the very notion
that there was such a thing as a VIP
Lane when the country was in the midst
of a pandemic and people were dying
is offensive
thank you madly Deputy speaker
Madam Deputy speaker members across this
house made repeated warnings about
contracts been awarded to companies
during the toughest days of the pandemic
especially those in the high priority
room Madam Deputy speaker it wasn't just
about PPE I raised concerns about
testing kits that put residents in care
homes in Blackburn at risk
today Madam Deputy speaker it's about a
failure of proper due diligence
no this was not a handless failure there
were failures that hampered their
responses to covert and enriched VIP
politicians well put in public at risk
constituents were eager to help
companies were eager to help the support
that was offered was tremendous
support to provide equipment
support that could have saved lives
lives hadn't been accepted
much much sooner I'd like to read a
section of an email from a constituent
who's a managing director of medical
equipment company in Blackburn we've
been gone 30 years they provide
equipment right across the world
this company in March uh contacted the
government to offer their services six
weeks later no response six weeks lost
the response when it did come was pretty
miserable gosh it pointed them to a link
on the government's website we still
never get any response okay
but the photograph I want to call is
what the managing director says None of
what I am seeing makes any sense when
all this comes down as one day it will
the lawyers will have a field day people
are using non-medically approved or
tested equipment whilst that are
recognized businesses that can supply
the necessary approved and tested PP
that have been ignored by the government
this is a company that was producing PPE
for councils and other public bodies who
had been let down by the government this
Scandal has been exposed and it is
important that cronyism is never allowed
to happen again
billions of pounds of public money
wasted life's lost and it's
disappointing so few members opposite
are here to listen to the failures
because you can only learn by your
mistakes and they're turning a day fear
to this Scandal accountability openness
honesty Integrity are all on the table
this evening and it'd be shameful if
members opposite failed to vote
this is a call for transparency and we
must not feel the public in these
situations ever again we must
demonstrate we've learned from mistakes
we must demonstrate transparency and if
as the minister claims there's nothing
to say here it's all been done properly
I would suggest you votes for this
motion and makes a promise to put the
papers in the library as soon as
possible
Peter grants
thank you madam Deputy speaker um and I
will certainly support in the motion uh
today I commend the opposition for the
voting part of the day too
um it's perhaps unfortunate that they
didn't realize there's another very very
interesting piece of contract lobbying
that was carried out and fair apparently
the contract was not awarded to the
person who did the lobbying who was
later described by a senior civil
servant as being incandescent with rage
that have chosen uh
supplier hadn't been successful in that
case I don't know whether it was the
same company we're talking about today
or a different one but it's quite clear
that there has been more than one
instance of lobbying in order to get
very lucrative contracts to companies
that are well connected Madam Deputy
speaker the minister when he spoke
referred several times to the fact that
the National Audit office have looked at
us in the public events might have
looked at it but that's okay Everton
must be fine I wonder why the minister
didn't choose to Enlighten those members
who haven't read those reports some of
the things were in those reports
national order office 26th of November
2020. some procurements were carried out
before all key controls were put in
place
the department had awarded contracts to
71 suppliers total value 1.5 billion
pounds before the financial and due
diligence process was standardized
National order office again in reference
to the the claim that 97 98 of all items
were usable the department estimate a
3.6 billion items 11 of the total with a
value of 2.9 billion pounds are not
currently suitable for Frontline service
in other words when we talked about 97
that have been usable it means we might
have paid for high-grade clinical
sterile equipment that can be used as a
face mask if you're cutting out good to
keep the dust out of your your lungs
that is not Frontline clinical use the
Public Accounts committee the department
this is in July this year the department
still two years after the contracts were
signed still lacks a stock management
system that enables it to fully
understand what PP it's got and fear it
is they don't know what they've got they
don't know where it is
Public Accounts committee again there
was insufficient due diligence checks at
the outside of the pandemic to prevent
potential profiteering and to identify
conflicts of interest exactly with
concerns that members of this race were
raising from day one uh being confirmed
Now by Public Accounts committee and
finally a conclusion from the Public
Accounts committee we are unsurprised to
see the reports of excessive profits and
conflicts of interest on PPE contracts
we can only speculate as to by the
minister to divide time to refer to any
other actual content of those reports
when he was addressing us earlier on the
minister said boosted 97 98 of items
where usable notice I said items they
didn't talk about the value of those
items because if you buy clinical if you
order clinical gloves and you get gloves
that aren't suitable for clinical use
they can still use them to keep the oil
off your hands of your service in your
car
but each of those pennies each as we've
already had there was millions of pounds
worth of sterile gowns that can't be
used because of Any stereo why is it
that Minister chose to give as partly
the truth but not the whole truth
Feelings by the government have meant
that there is a desk a huge question
mark over this whole process it means
that the legitimate firms and the high
the very hard-working professional civil
servants are left with a question mark
over them
and it's very clear that in some cases a
minority of cases to some significant
cases those question marks are not
question marks at all they are
exclamation marks
it's quite clear that things have
happened that should not have been
allowed to happen that require further
investigation the government may have
its reasons for wanting to keep this
information not only that necessarily
from the public but from the Public
Accounts committee
that information has got to be released
and it has to be left the Judgment of
the impartial Public Accounts committee
to decide what is made public and what
Escape Seeker
yeah yeah
well my uh honorable friends have laid
out very clearly the shocking Scandal
that this PPE contract is
and people have also mentioned people
working hard at the front line putting
themselves in danger to help others and
of course all those who lost our loved
ones
to concentrate on is the damage that the
VIP Lanes have done to Loyal reputable
companies the backbone of British
business who were offering to be
generous to go the extra mile to help
rather than looking for chances to rip
the taxpayer off
BCB International is a company which
operates in my constituency and in
Cardiff and a long established company
manufacture and supply of life-saving
equipment including medical equipment
and their primary customers in the UK
are the ministry of Defense the ministry
of justice and many police forces and
they export approximately 40 percent of
their turnover the sort of things they
make include a very good fuel for
camping gas stoves called fire dragon
and the point is they were registered
they were known to the mod they were
known to the MOJ they were a company
which had a good reputation and were
ready to go in March 2020 they were in
production of their high quality hand
sanitizer Dr Brown's infinitely they
employed up to 100 staff and worked 24
7. they're 80 sanitizer passed all the
appropriate tax and Dr Brown's as well
liked and used by the NHS in Wales as
well as well as a number of police
forces and other public bodies is
now
due to the ppe's shortages the UK
government committed early on the
pandemic to back British business and
the government's UK make program headed
up by Lord Dayton who was tasked to
unleash the potential of UK industry to
scale up domestic PPE manufacturing as
Lord Dayton said in May 2020 as
countries around the world face
unprecedented demand for PPE British
industry is stepping forward to make
sure vital pieces of equipment reach our
workers on the front line my role is to
increase our homegrown PPE supplies both
now and in the future by investing in
the potential of UK Manufacturing
but I understand that the UK make policy
was subsequently withdrawn in September
2020. now in may 2020 following the
government initiatives
BCB invested 700 000 in new sanitizer
production equipment they also bought in
high quality ffv3 face masks from Europe
set up gun production and made auction
bottle bags and they supplied all of
these successfully and on timed the
Welsh NHS and Russian English police
forces and the mod
and for March 2020 the company had
regularly tried to sell their British PP
products to the Department of Health and
Social care and they provided a brief
overview of just some of the names that
they were in contact with which I
haven't time to read out now but they
tell me that they made these contacts
and many many other emails but they have
never ever ever been contacted back and
this is an absolute utter disgrace and I
think today we have seen why that was
the case and there was no need for it to
be the case for loyal good companies who
did absolutely everything they possibly
could turned their Workforce to working
for the country were completely ignored
and as has been mentioned it was not
like this in Wales and they spoke very
very highly of the Welsh procurement
procedure and it's no wonder then that
the auditor general in Wales said in
contrast the position described by the
Neo in England we saw no evidence of a
priority being given to potential
suppliers depending on who referred them
those are extremely strong words from an
auditor depending on who referred them
referring to what was happening in
England and the Welsh government did put
in place good Arrangements overall that
is such a contrast and that is what is
so damaging to all the good businesses
in this country who want to play by the
rules thank you madam Deputy speaker
Minister Flora Anderson
thank you madam Deputy speaker I'm
delighted to be able to close today's
debate on behalf of his Majesty's
opposition and I share the indignation
of my honorable friend the shadow
Chancellor of the duchy of Lancaster
that we are once again having to come
here to table a humble address to force
the government to come clean with the
British public it's all about
transparency there are questions that
need to be answered the members opposite
can either support today's binding vote
to force ministers to complain or be
complicit in the continuing cover
the choice is theirs and their
constituents are watching
the VIP Lane is a national Scandal that
will cast a long Shadow for years to
come it does take us back to the dark
days of 2020 when covid was spreading
when people were dying and there wasn't
enough PPE for those Frontline workers
schools donated goggles volunteers sowed
gowns in their homes nurses and Care
home workers had to resort to wearing
bin bags
the members today from glenelguent Brent
counts Brent Central Bradford West
Nottingham East and National have very
well articulated the anger that is felt
by our constituents across the country
that they want to have questions
answered did this shift to procurement
was necessary no one's denying that we
had to have false procurement that
didn't lead to leave to whole
procurement procedures being jettisoned
along the way this whole failure to
provide usable PPE huge contrast to
Shell companies industrial scale waste
Madame Deputy speaker of taxpayers money
and then an industrial scale cover-up
12.6 billion pounds were spent in total
on PPE but 8 billion pounds of this was
written off four billion pounds of this
was not up to standard was unusable 3.6
billion pounds worth of contracts raised
one or more red flags for possible
corruption according to Transparency
International
176 contracts are now in legal dispute
worth 2.6 billion pounds and the
consequences continue as we've heard
from the members today
up to a few weeks ago 770
000 pounds was being spent every day I
had to check this every several times
really every day it couldn't be right
770
000 pounds was being spent
every day to store the port 44 PPE here
and in China that was over 5 million
pounds a week 280 million pounds a year
that's enough to pay free School meals
of all primary school children in
Manchester Birmingham Leeds Liverpool
and Nottingham put together Madam Deputy
speaker or 8 000 nurses a year I've
heard the clarification from the
minister that that amount has reduced
and what that's very welcome but it's
still four hundred thousand pounds a day
120 million PP items are being stored in
China what is going on I speak today for
the millions who are sat in freezing
homes relying on food banks during this
cost of living crisis and hearing that
Britain is being ripped off by the
Tories
the chair of council at the British
Medical Association said the deadly
mismanagement around the supply of PPE
is one of greatest failings of this
government's handling of the pandemic
there must be a reckoning that Madame
Deputy speaker the
power for a decade when covet began but
it didn't have good enough emergency
plans in place and that's why they
didn't have enough stockpiles of PPE
that's why they had to Panic by they
bypassed existing scaled up
british-based providers of PPE they
chose shell companies that had no
experience they gave huge contracts and
jettisoned those good Contracting
procedures other countries managed to do
it at the same time we should have been
able to do it too fair enough to move to
emergency Contracting to streamline
Contracting to speed it up but no checks
on companies Madam Deputy speaker no
checks to see if the masks met NHS
standards did no Minister intervene and
say look this isn't right emergency
procurement procedures don't mean no
procurement procedures did no Minister
say assure me these companies can
deliver this is tax man money did no
Minister say insure me that the VIP Lane
is not being used for mates for donors
for Pub landlords to get these contracts
over actual PPE contract did no Minister
say assure me that the contract ensures
that if the PPE is faulty the taxpayer
will not pay no it seems not what
happened was wrong and it's
disappointing that ministers are keeping
on defending it if ministers don't own
this admit it was wrong they won't make
the changes and it could well happen
again I think that's what everyone in
the country knows is true that the first
instincts of the conservative party if
there was another pandemic tomorrow or
another an emergency will not be to go
to correct procurement procedures and
make sure that our taxpayers money is
not spent wrongly
Madame Deputy speaker I'd like to tell
you about two types of company the first
is Arco and we've heard of others from
Members Arco is a whole based market
leader in PPE production they have 135
years of experience and work with a
hundred and ten thousand customers and
they hold key framework agreements
including with NHS supply chain
they're very experienced in provision of
expert advice and appropriate and
compliant PPE during epidemics including
foot and mouth mad cow disease swine flu
Ebola they have their own accredited
product Assurance lab 400
000 square foot National Distribution
Center and a sourcing team based in
China all of that it was in place at the
beginning of covid they had PPE of the
standard required manufacturing standard
required manufactured ready to go they
contacted the government and what was
the reply Madame Deputy speaker they
were ignored their officer offers went
unanswered when PPE Med Pro wasn't even
a company until May 2020 they were
awarded a contract for 122 million
pounds for provision of 25 million gowns
and another one of 81 million pounds for
face marks pestfix was a pest control
company with net assets of eighteen
thousand pounds in 2019
um the the director Joe England met the
department for Health and Social Care's
Chief commercial Officer Steve Oldfield
at the 80th birthday party of Mr
oldfield's father-in-law they were
referred to the high priority Lane went
on to win nearly 350 million pounds of
contracts but were fined 70 million
pounds for delivery of faulty masks and
gowns there was the mobile phone case
designer that recorded a million pounds
loss in 2019 they were referred to the
high priority Lane by a former
conservative party chairman they
received a 13 million pound contract to
provide PPE Melo designs was a fashion
accessories company that was referred by
The Honorable member for sorry Heath
David Miller was a donor to his
leadership campaign in 2016. the company
received contracts of 117 70 million
pounds I under Capital was a family
investment firm specializing in currency
trading offshore property and private
Equity an obvious go-to for supplying
PPE they were referred by Andrew Mills
an unpaid advisor to the Board of Trade
which is chaired by The Honorable member
for South West Norfolk and I have
advised her of mentioning her the
problem is that they provided 40 million
pounds of unusable face masks yet still
posted a 25 million pound gross profit
in 2020 and the list goes on what do we
need instead Madam Deputy speaker we
need a national resilience strategy we
need a procurement bill that's not full
of loopholes we need a whole system
approach not a mad panic and pick your
mates to make money approach currently
accepted that's why this matters Madam
Deputy speaker that's why we're asking
to see the go the documents I hope the
whole house will support this motion and
ensure the government gets the most
basic responsibility of government
rights that is to keep us safe
foreign
Deputy speaker now to make sure that I
get to them I want to respond to some of
the very important points made by
backbench members at the very top of my
remarks now the member for whole East
who's certainly not his place at the
moment mentioned Arco not getting a
contract but my understanding is that
they did get the contract
um so we should resolve what is going to
mind saying is they actually did get a
contract
um our guy a little bit The Honorable oh
God you mentioned the two different
contracts were made in Pro and it's very
important to be clear one of those
contracts did deliver BP was delivered
that's fine one didn't and that's one
that we're taking enforcement action on
because of course we are like all these
contacts we are just as Keen as
everybody else to make sure that we get
that to his money uh uh whether we get
good value for money for taxpayers and
reinforce whenever things haven't been
delivered the honorable member for
Bradford West
uh sorry the only one before playing I
went first
um called for the publication of
companies that were in the high priority
group and then got contracts something
which happened in November 2021 The
Honorable member for Bradford West I do
slightly disagree with one point that
she made which is that the argument that
we shouldn't have had any contracts with
firms that hadn't previously been PP
just one moment that actually argued
that we shouldn't have any contacts with
firms that hadn't previously been PPE
suppliers and of course lots of new
firms were coming into the market a part
of our drive to get more UK Supply uh
relied on that very point I was going to
complete my tour of people's
contributions so far the honorable
member for Brent uh Central said that we
should uh donate should donate and reuse
PPE and I'm pleased to tell her that
that is precisely uh what we are doing
The Honorable member for Edinburgh West
uh said that we're in the middle of a
major cost of living uh issue and uh
she's absolutely correct that's why
we're spending 55 billion on energy
support that's why we have the 900 pound
payment for eight million uh poorer
households that's why we're raising the
national living wage to a record level
which is worth about 1 600 pounds for a
full-term worker now the members for
Blackburn and Milena
I I will do but I'm trying to respond to
those points first let's see if you can
hold on I will get there The Honorable
members for Blackbird and the following
both made the point that we wanted to
get more UK producers making PP my
honorable friends already made the point
that we've gone from one percent of uh
fpp3 masks being made in the UK to 75
I'd also mentioned our work with moderna
to get more development and production
of vaccines happening in the UK as part
of that exciting deal
uh the member for Glenn Ross uh said
that somebody one of the potential
supplies had been incandescent with rage
because they didn't get a contract
now that is the sister working contracts
were being turned down 90 of those who
went through the
um Madame Deputy speaker I'm desperately
trying to respond to all the order order
order
give the minister a chance to respond to
all the questions I've tried to give
enough time for that Minister now let
them get on with it until I'm Keen to
reply to them
um he talked about
um only three percent and I'm literally
responding to the honorable gentleman
and he talked about uh three this point
about only three percent not being
reusable and implied that some of the
other things oh they were only fit for
servicing your car now to be clear about
that some of these things are have a
have a different clinical use so for
example the NHS tends to use and wants
to use aprons on a roll when you have
the choice once you have a normal PP
market and what we do therefore is use
the flat pack ones that we had and
donate them to Care Homes also
self-assembly visors not preferred in
the NHS because they take a bit of time
to assemble hence giving them to
dentists and the like and there have
been two different mentions of uses of
the word writing off uh in this debate
and it's very important to be clear
about the difference between these two
things some people talk about writing
off for things that are not usable
and that is the three percent only three
percent of what was purchased is in that
category and then there is a different
accounting use of the words uh writing
off uh usually something you have to do
we bought let's be clear we bought a
load of PPE because we needed it in the
middle of the pandemic it was more
expensive during that time it is was
worth more than that it is now and that
is the accounting meaning but let's be
clear about the two different uses of uh
writing off now there were so many there
were so many questions I'm not quite
sure which interventions to to give way
to but I think I should I should uh
start at the back
Nick Smith can I thank Mr for giving me
but just to say he attributed uh
comments to me which I did not make and
I just want to put that on the record
but I do have a question for him does
the minister accept that there has been
excessive profits made on the back of
some of these PPE contracts
I'm about to go through the due process
that we went through in the incredibly
forensic work that our civil servants
did and just to be clear again for the
benefit of the house
ministers did not make decisions on
contracts officials as usual made the
decisions on contracts and I'll talk
more about the process that we went
through in a very short time that we
have remaining so we've seen during the
dark days of the pandemic a collective
approach that saw hundreds of millions
of life-saving vaccine doses delivered
The Lodges testing infrastructure in
Europe established from a standing start
and the distribution of tens of millions
of items of PPE a uniquely complex
challenge even in normal times but a
particular challenge went the entire
world was trying to get these Goods all
of my members opposite don't want to
have the courtesy to listen to the
answers to the questions that they have
asked a strange a strange approach
um so we delivered 20 billion items to
the front line and to our broader
Workforce and we're still in fact
delivering 5 million items a month
I was enough to deliver uh even the
response to a worst case scenario which
fortunately uh didn't emerge and that's
why we have that 20 excess stock that I
uh mentioned before it is simply not the
case as uh one honorable member
mentioned that we had five times too
much BP simply uh simply not the case
but let's remember the context Madam
Deputy speaker it was the former leader
of the opposition the member for
Islington North who said it was a matter
of safety and patient safety and we
agreed that's why we acted is the shadow
Hill secretary at the time who said our
NHS and social Care staff deserve the
very best protective clothing and they
urgently need it and we agreed and it
was the show that current Shadow
councilor who called for a national
effort which leaves no stone unturned
and that is exactly what we did and that
is
stop shouting
Minister say that
you don't want to repeat it no she
doesn't want to repeat it clearly let me
be clear Madame Deputy speaker at every
point in the procurement process the
process is rightly run by our brilliant
commercial professionals ministers
aren't involved in the procurement
process ministers aren't involved in the
value of contracts ministers aren't
involved in the scope of contracts and
ministers aren't involved in the length
of contract something echoed by the
National Audit office whose report
concluded that the ministers have
properly declared their interests and I
quote there is no evidence of their
involvement in procurement decisions or
contract management
the role of ministers exactly what you
would expect approaches from suppliers
were passed on to civil servants for an
independent assessment and to look at
the scale of the effort again Madam
Deputy speaker 19 000 companies made
offers around 430 were processed through
the high priority group only 12 of those
resulted in a contract for 51 firms and
that group was primarily about managing
the many many requests that were coming
into ministers from people right across
this house from people across the
country who were desperate to help with
that National challenge of getting more
PPE and there had to be a way of dealing
with them but to be clear due diligence
was carried out on every single company
Financial accountability sat with a
senior civil servant all procurement
decisions were taken by civil servants
and a team of over 400 civil servants
process referrals and understood due
diligence checks a huge operation run by
the Civil Service and I thank them for
their work in getting our NHS the PPE
that it needed let me be clear Madam
Deputy speaker I'm not going to stand
here and say there weren't any lessons
to be learned course there are
but we should be clear about what the
lessons are and despite the global risk
to get PPE only three percent of the
material Source couldn't be used as fit
for purpose but we have built lots of
polite resilient Supply chains we're
implementing the recommendations of the
Boardman review of pandemic uh preparing
us in our full I've mentioned the the
growth of UK procurement of face masks
and of vaccines
but in closing Madame Deputy speaker I
want to thank all of us who've been
involved in this important conversation
we should be rightly proud of what was
achieved during those dark and difficult
days at the start of a pandemic
operating in the continuance conditions
are considerable uncertainty we were in
a situation Madame Deputy speaker where
literally there was something going on
if you didn't turn up with the cash
things were removed that you had bought
from the warehouses that was the global
race that we were in to Source these
things and I think that the team the 400
strong team of civil servants who led
this process did a remarkable job from a
standing staff of sourcing the goods we
needed there have been I think during
this this uh debate we've heard a number
of deliberate obfuscations I think of
the different things that ministers and
officials do to be clear all of these
decisions went through an eight-stage
forensic process which was run by
entirely by officials and it did not get
you a contract to go into this high
quality group that was simply about
managing the sheer number of bids for
contracts that we're coming in to people
across this house and at the time
although memories are very short and the
barracking has continued
the question is that the question beat
up pushes managers or that opinion say I
I of the contrary no I think the eyes
have it the eyes have it the question is
As on the order paper as well as that
opinion say aye
of the contrary no
I think the eyes have it I think the
eyes have it the it's inadvisable for
people to shout other things if I'm
listening for the eyes having it
I think the eyes have it
the eyes have it
and so that's
concludes the debate and we move now to
motion number three on exiting the
European Union animals motion number
four on animals motion number five on
Financial Services Mr to move the
question is As on the order paper is
that opinion say I
of the contouring no I think the eyes
have it the eyes have it we can't we
can't we can't continue making all this
noise when I'm on my feet
thank you
we now come to motion number six
relating to the Committee of Public
Accounts and Bill wiggin thank you madam
speaker I'd beg to move it says on the
order papers is that opinion say I I of
the country no I think they like to have
it the eyes have it and motion number
seven
relating to the public administration
and constitutional Affairs committee so
Bill Wigan I beg to move the question is
As on the order papers when I said
opinion say I I of the country no the
eyes have it the eyes have it
petition
Scott Benton thank you madam Deputy
speaker I'm pleased to present this
petition on access to NHS dental care in
Blackpool to the house this petition has
been signed by over 790 residents which
is also on behalf of the thousands of my
constituents who are currently without
an NHS dentist it is clear that urgent
reform of the current Dental contract is
required in order to incentivize
dentists to practice in areas such as
Blackpool the petitioners therefore
request that the House of Commons urge
for government to act quickly to improve
access to NHS dental care in Blackpool
in here
[Music]
petition access to NHS dental care in
Blackpool
my next move this house
the question is that these hugs do not
adjourn Peter Grant yeah yeah
thank you very much Madam Deputy speaker
and I hope it's an order before I begin
trying to place on record my heart
taking congratulations to my honorable
friend from Aberdeen South I'm honorable
pen from for Paisley and renfish
yourself who have just been announced as
a new leader and Deputy leader of the
SNP group here at Westminster
um now for my congratulations to both of
them Deputy speaker I'm capability of
the opportunity to raise in the house
the woeful performance of the department
for working pensions and responding to
queries for members of parliament I was
particularly Keen that the debate title
would not simply talk about
correspondence but would cover all forms
of communication or non-communication
because the Department's repeated
failure to put in place a reliable and
efficient way for MPS and their
caseworkers to phone with urgent
inquiries to be able to speak to someone
who actually understands the case as a
recurring theme that in all causes
immense frustration for MPS of all
parties let me quote just one of the
main interest cases I could refer to you
Alison's got a job that it's low paid so
she gets Universal Credit and she should
have got a cost a living payment in July
it didn't arrive
this remember is money that the
government has accepted she needs she
absolutely needs in order to make my
ends meet
by early September Alison contacted my
office in desperation she told us she
had stopped the payments for her rent
her council tax of Internet service
within 10 days she had to cancel her car
insurance and she was being referred to
Sheriff Offices for council tax areas
my caseworkers went through the whole
rigmarole a phone and emailing all the
right addresses at DWP but they couldn't
speak to or correspond with the people
who were responsible for making
Allison's payment none of the people in
my staff were able to speak to had any
Authority even to ask for her payment to
be prioritized two promised payment
dates were not kept Alison eventually
received the money she was owed on the
28th of October over three months later
it's not the fault of overbought DWP
staff that they couldn't do anything to
help it's the fault of the way the DWP
has chosen to make unnecessarily
difficult for MPS to do our job of
providing support to constituents in
need
for child maintenance service caseworks
air staff have access to an MP hotline
and a dedicated email address until 2020
there was an MP hotline for working age
benefits such as job Seekers allowance
employment support allowance income
support this gave my caseworkers and
others a direct line to the local
Regional Network National complaints
Resolution Team based in Glasgow in my
case for Stafford access to the various
benefit systems and they could contact
other DWP departments with queries they
could chase down responses they could
also be contactable directly by email
with introduction of Universal Credit
that hotline became less useful
all those DWP on the other end continued
to do the best they could eventually the
hotline for working age benefits just
disappeared altogether but the casework
certainly did not
the current confidential list of all hot
MP hotline contacts says in